I have a bunch of shapes here, let's think
about what they are
so this first shape here, you probably
recognize it is the shape of the moon in
the sky
or atleast on a full moon and we call it
a circle. Now
what makes it a circle when you get
further in math we come up with fancier
ways to define a circle but one with
think about it is if we take the center
the circle
and if we go from one side
of the circle to the other side circle
through the center
that's always going to be the same
length so that's the same length
as is this as this is on his way to the
center the circle
as that now
if that the circle what would something
like this to be
what you might call this an oval.
all circles are ovals but this
oval is not a circle because if you have
its center
see right over there this distance going
in that direction
is going to be much shorter or just
shorter
than this distance right over here so
this one right over here
is not a circle, this one is. Now what
about the shape over here that has three
sides
one two three
you could also say it has three corners
one two
three if you have three sides we call that a
triangle
Tri angle whenever you see this Tri over
hear that's a good
sign that you're dealing with the number
three. This is a triangle
has three sides note about these shapes
over here
these shapes are interesting how many
shapes. So how many sides
do these shapes have. Well if you count them
you see that this one up here in purple
has one two three four sides
this one has one two three
four sides, this has one two
three four sides, this has one
two three four sides. So they all have four sides.
So a name for any shape that has four
sides is quadrilateral
Quad
dri quadrilateral
quadrilateral and when you see this quad
at the beginning of the word
it's a pretty good sign that you're
dealing with the number four
four sides, four sides
that's what quadrilateral means but
these are all different special cases of
quadrilaterals
and actually you could even have a quadrilateral that
looks like this, could even have a
quadrilateral that look like this. One
two three four sides as long as as four sides
it's a quadrilateral
Let's think about each of these so this
shape right over here
what you might see is the corners the
corners
all come in, sometimes is called square
sometimes
you could call it a right angle so
and notice I could put little small squares
here. SO if all four corners are square
or they're all come in at a right angle
like this then you're dealing with a
rectangle
you are dealing with the rectangle and so
just to be clear
this down here is not a rectangle notice
this corner right over if I tried to
pull all square here
it would either look like this or
doesn't
it doesn't the two sides aren't two
sides of a square
or would look like or it would look like
this
so this is not a square corner neither
it is this
or neither is this so this is not a
rectangle
all four corners need to be square this
one also is not a rectangle
notice the corners are not
the corners are not right angles so
this is a direct rectangle this is a
direct rectangle and what about this
well I can do that I can put little
squares
I could put all squares in the corner or
I could see that they are all right all
the corners
are right angles so this actually is a
rectangle as well
so these are both these are both
rectangles
now you might recognize this purple one
on the left is a special type a
rectangle
not only are all the corners square
not all do they have
these right angles but all the sides are
the same length
at least it looks like it from the
picture this side is the same length as this
side is the same length as that side
same length as that side. So if the sides are
of same length and all the corners are
square where they have right angles,
then we call it a square
so this right over here is a, this
right over here is a square special type
a rectangle
this one not all the side to the same
this one all the sides are the same
out if we go down here looks like all
the sides are the same one
two three four
but it doesn't have
square corners. Notice if I tried to put
a little square here
it wouldn't fit perfectly, if I tried
square here doesn't fit perfectly these
aren't right angles
So if all four sides are the same and
that's all we know about it
we call it a rhombus. We call it a
rhombus
so you might be saying, the square all
four sides are the same, is that a rhombus?
yes it is. So the square is a rectangle
it's a rectangle and
is a rhombus so this last shape here
this last quadrilateral
what's interesting about it is you have
two of the side's going in the same
direction
so this one right over here knows what I
mean by the same direction it sometimes
is called parallel
if I draw two lines here these two lines
are never going to cross each other
so these two lines are parallel if you
have opposite one pair of opposite sides
that are parallel
we call them trapezoids we call them
trapezoids.
Notice the other blinds the other
opposite sides
these will cross, these will cross
eventually to that right over there is
called a trapezoid.